[Music]
so
welcome to uh today's youtube video
i have with me um sajad who's actually
the the ceo i believe
of the british landlord association and
we're going to be talking a little bit
about property of course because this is
a property channel
but also a little bit about what the
british landlord association is
and how it works so firstly sadjad thank
you so much for your time today i know
you're extremely busy
it's really really good to have you on
the on the channel thank you for having
me thank you so why don't we start just
why don't you just tell me just give me
a little introduction as to what the
british landlord association is
and how it came into existence okay good
question
uh the british landlord association uh
have been
it was established over four years ago
uh we felt it was necessary to have
an association i think some of these
other associations weren't providing we
felt
the service that they ought to provide
and so therefore that's why the british
landlord association is set up
with other landlord association they all
have their strengths and
weaknesses so i'm not knocking anybody
or any other association
um the nrla um who um
you know is the other uh landlord
association they're um
uh campaigning you know it's fantastic
you know where credit is due
you know they're very very good at that
and an established um
association that has you know all the
ability and
all the mechanisms uh to deal with that
um
so anyway the british landlord
association was set up over four years
ago
it provides everything that any landlord
association
uh you know should uh just like the
you know at the nrla or um
you know some of the other southern land
lord association who are also known as
houzz now i think you know they change
their name yeah
um so we provide all of those the
difference with
the british landlord association is
we we we're free generally free
you know is totally free to join uh
we're also
the only landlord associations that
cover commercial and residential
residential is when it comes to
you know legal documents and i suppose
uh legal advice it's a bit
easier and a lot of people get into
residential property and they
learn the ropes as they get along
commercial is a bit different
so therefore i suspect that
that's why you haven't got a landlord
association that does commercial and
residential
to be able to really properly um have
lawyers who can deal with that element
of it i i advising
their members is is not that easy
so therefore that's probably i would
imagine
whether that's why we're the only ones
that cover uh residential and commercial
uh our legal side is probably our
strength
in the sense that we've got in-house
lawyers
not just other landlords advising other
landlords they are
practicing lawyers who can advise
landlords
um so they've got a wealth of experience
in commercial
and residential they deal with problems
in every single day the potential
problems that when you come across
defenses and things like that um and
they're perfect in really advising
you know any landlord who rings them for
any potential problem
and that's where i think when you look
at our members
when they do speak to our helpline
you know they they really are impressed
by
the depth of information and advice that
they get
so that's probably our uh strength
yeah that's right everything as well is
with the british landlord association i
know that
you don't charge for membership and i i
also believe that a lot of
there's a lot of volunteers that also
help out and you you'll run with
volunteers
i just want to know i i mean i mean the
service i think is fabulous what you
offer
for for landlords and sometimes as a
landlord you can be a little bit
unsure as to what to do in the situation
with the with the tenant eviction ban
and the different rules that are
happening and you don't want to you know
it's really really good to have not only
people that can
um support and answer questions but also
the fact that you've got legal advisors
on there
it's a fabulous service and that's why i
wanted to have you on the youtube
channel
to sort of just tell my members about
what it is that you can offer because i
think it's a great service
talk to me a little bit about the reason
and emission
behind why you
do what you do and why so many people
are prepared to give up their time and
volunteer for free because that's a very
interesting point
yeah yeah it is i i've been a landlord
since the age of
18 myself and i've been a landlord for
38 years
um in property it's you know i've made
money
uh i've been successful and with god's
grace i
you know i'm thankful for that but with
that comes experience
like always we make mistakes and we
learn so there is something that um
i have uh to offer and same as the other
people who work
for the bla uh they feel the same way
that you know they've got the experience
and they can share that and it's nice to
be able to help somebody
yeah but help somebody with no
motivation you know there's there's
nothing in it there's nothing in it for
me there's nothing in it for any
anybody else who works with vla so
it is generally trying to help other
landlords because
everybody who works with bla they've got
experience they're they're mature
and they've all done reasonably well
and they feel that there's something to
put back into
the community and help landlords uh
but also in a fair way that you have a
fair market
that uh for landlords and
rentals and that's the only the only way
it can work
um as you know you know landlords do
some landlords do get you know a bad
name
and i think it's important for landlords
association like us
to a um
you know explain to i suppose
you know the people who are not
landlords uh to
just see how you know uh landlords work
and they're not they're not all bad you
know just a few landlords doesn't mean
that you know
that they're all bad and some of the
stories that you hear
especially now with covert 19
i think personally you know landlords
uh the mountain landers that have
written off rent arrays have been so
graceful
towards their tenants it's remarkable
you know how people pull together
and the government has called and said
look you know
don't evict unless you really really
have to you know
try to negotiate with your tenant uh
tenants
and what we've seen is just just uh
uh so impressive um you know where
that was written off five months six
months i'm not saying look everybody can
do that there's a lot of ladle
struggling there's a lot of laboratories
who have mortgages
and the mortgage will just cover the uh
in the service of rent
but those few who can are doing that
uh and so you know this bad press a lot
of times
landlords get i think is unbeaten and i
think
many industries you know there's good
and bad right landlords
do get also because you own
a few houses they assume that you really
really can afford to go without the rent
but
actually some landlords think you know
well that's their
that's their plans so in terms of being
a member there
because there's a little dual man
what do you act as a man what sort of
support services do you get
okay well the first one is that
if landlord needs legal advice they can
bring
the helpline and speak to a lawyer the
second one
is tax taxation if they've got issues
with tax or tax advice they can uh they
have access to an accountant
uh that will give them free advice uh
and any representation if they need that
there are also then the legal documents
that
members can download which are
potentially all the
documents that any landlord would need
with template letters and things like
that
then you've got other services which
is insurance and credit checks and
things like that
those are all discounted because the bla
isn't really set up to make a profit so
a lot of these services we provide we
pass
100 of um
the discount to our members so they you
know they come for us but they go
directly to
the source through us and that way they
get
technically that that service should be
cheaper
through the bla than anywhere else
because we don't take a percentage
we we do take a percentages um
on the insurance product and
on just i think about just a few
documents
that we charge for
and on the on the credit checks because
the credit checks is something that
you have to do manually you have to
employ somebody to do that
um i won't say it's a profit but it's a
service we also have a daily paper which
is published
seven days a week
we think that's quite an impressive
paper it has news around the world
from the residential sector commercial
sector of landlords
and it's got all sorts of wealth of
you know sort of news different aspects
of news taxation evictions
legislation et cetera et cetera again
you know we email that to our members uh
or they can access it directly from our
website
yeah so yourself you're a landlord
you've got a lot of um people that are
involved in the british landlord
association it's not just you
there's quite a big team and you've got
um how many members seventeen thousand
members all right so it's just over
twenty seven thousand limbs now
fabulous you still you are presumably
you're still a landlord today you've got
a portfolio you've got tenants yes yeah
i'm uh i'm the ceo of bla i'm also
a lawyer and a landlord and still a
landlord yes
so talk to me about some of the
hardships that landlords have to go
through at the moment i mean i know
there's been a lot of
uh legislation um of course with the
tenant eviction ban
and it you know we understand why it's
in place um do you think now is
a particularly difficult time to be a
landlord and what are some of the ways
that you can or maybe you don't maybe
you think that now
um it is not a difficult time to be a
landlord um i mean a lot of people are
moving into other strategies like
development and
you know different different areas of
property to make money uh
what do you think right now 2021 uh
about being a landlord
uh it is difficult um you you know the
the taxes there's so many different
taxes now
and uh i we anticipate there will be
even further taxes
uh on landlords uh we don't know how the
government's going to hit us but
we you know it's one of the seconds we
believe that's going to be hit
there's a raft of different legislation
as you know
and that legislation we say some of it
is unfair uh and so that some of that
needs to be challenged and we must
challenge it
um so that things like that uh
we as an association need to work on uh
but nevertheless
uh look the interest rate are nearly you
know close to sort of nil
so where do you invest property still
when you look at the options you know
the alternative is probably still
pretty you know good investment and
despite
you know the problems uh but there are
other models
and you know you're you're a guru and
one of them you know that's that's uh
that gives you a fairly good margin um
so rent rent um and
property development you know flipping
properties uh
you can make money that's still good
yeah
and i think as well you know there's
always there's always problems and
there's always solutions
like with the tax um section 24 there
are ways around it and that's why it's
so important that people have got the
right support the right guidance
i mean i've got a training company
you've got a very different setup i
think
my business is very much around teaching
people as you know how to
make money whereas yours is yours is uh
a different more about you know dealing
with tenants and
and the legal aspects um which is why i
think i wanted to do this
collaboration with you because i think
it's my members will benefit a lot from
being
a member of the british landlord
association and i think that i would
urge
i mean of course um if you're a landlord
what have you got to lose
by being a member um what was it that
because you've been quite active on the
facebook group
um property investors with samuel leeds
what was it
that connected you with me and how did
that come about
well i've seen some of your youtube
videos uh i think what you do and what
you offer
is really impressive and it's very
useful
uh there are people who want to be
landlords they do want to get into
property
uh by the time i when i started when i
was eight you know 18 years old
i didn't have somebody like you i didn't
have the
courses that you know you offer i wish
they were there
but they weren't so through the process
you know i went it was
learning and making mistakes yeah and i
think
your courses that you offer the service
you offer
uh it's you you know you can alleviate
some of the potential problems and
pitfalls and that's the
the benefit of you know your service and
when i look at your videos and
everything else and i thought you know
you provided a very good service
and credit to you you know because look
you're in property you don't need to do
this
you know you you can just concentrate
one element of it
but i think one of the things that you
look at and say you know i've
i've got this experience and i cannot
threaten and
and that's what you're doing and um and
i commend you for that
yeah yeah i really appreciate that and
there's definitely a lot of satisfaction
as well
you know for in in giving back and
helping people and i mean
exactly and this is why when we set up a
british landmark association
when we say okay you know we we
don't get paid we you know we're
volunteers but that's the satisfaction
you're
helping somebody and so that is a really
good feeling
yeah and the group you know a really
active facebook group with over 30
000 um members which is which which is
which is great
there are a lot of free resources out
there i think that
you know i mean yeah you as you know
i've got some paid for training
and um and that's and that's great and
wonderful but there's so much
information online there's so many
supportive groups
of course you need to be careful where
you get your information from because
there's also a lot of
rubbish on the internet and you know if
you go on forums and online articles
there's a lot of things that are
blatantly incorrect which is well i
think it's so so important that people
get
um their information from the right
sources and um
but but it is out there and and thanks
to people like you and british landlord
association
there is support there is training there
is guidance
so how how can people connect with you
and how can they become a member
you say it's free are there any catches
how does it work and how can people
become a member of the british landlord
association
uh you go on our website uh and uh just
where it says join you click that and it
takes you literally anything between
30 seconds to a minute to sign up um
because it's a free association there is
no credit card or anything like that
it is literally that quick uh there is
no catches
it is genuinely free um
that's excellent well i would urge
everybody listening to get registered
and become a member of the british land
association um the british standard
association are very active within
property investors with samuel lee's
facebook group
group if you're not a member of that as
well join join the facebook group get
support
and remember as a landlord it can be
lonely as a property investor as a
landlord
but you know it doesn't have to be and
and you can get around
other people doing it so sajad i commend
you for the work that you're doing
thanks for coming on the channel and i
look forward to keeping in touch
thank you very much excellent